leemans bottineau et depuis décembre
dernier la nouvelle et discrète miss
france et pour la toute première fois la
jeune femme s'est exprimée sur un moment
particulièrement difficile de son sacre
de miss celui de l'épreuve toujours
polémique du défilé en maillot de bain
beaucoup d'autres en maillot de bain
mais pour nous jeunes femmes d'un
nécessite beaucoup de courage et
beaucoup d'efforts sur soi pour arriver
devant l'union de téléspectateurs et
assumer son corps la jeune femme
explique que cette épreuve a demandé des
efforts on a tout eu ça donc travailler
dur prendre sur nous enfin ce média moi
je vois geste est ce que ça m'a coûté
d'être jean dionis france c'est pas
différent qu'un concours de beauté ce
n'est pas la première fois que cette
épreuve de l'élection fait parler en
2018 alors que le concours miss america
avait décidé de supprimer cette épreuve
jugée archaïque en plein mouvement mitu
et de la remplacer par un échange avec
le jury en france la question s'était
posée à l'époque sylvie tellier avait
répondu catégoriquement on peut défiler
en maillot de bain et être féministe on
n'a jamais obligé une jeune femme à
faire ce qu'elle ne voulait pas faire
elles sont libres de choisir le maillot
de bain ou la robe qu'elles veulent
parfaite geneviève de fontenay dénoncer
quand l utilisation de bikini plutôt que
de maillots une pièce tout comme de
nombreux téléspectateurs pour qui cette
épreuve n'a plus sa place en 2020 alors
pour vous faut-il retirer les preuves
des maillots de bain du concours miss
france
[Musique]
ça alors ça ça fait débat à fond à fond
à fond on va voir exactement ce que dit
clémence bottineau miss france que vous
allez nous dire après faut-il arrêter le
défilé en maillot
je vous pose la question sachez qu'ici
il n'y a qu'une personne qui est pauvre
et tout le monde est contre arrêtez
arrêtez le défilé en maillot
eric valérie raymond kelly isabelle
géraldine et mathieu qui n'a pas répondu
mais je me doute bien il veut voir des
maillots celui-ci comprend pas pourquoi
il ya ce déferlement de critiques autour
de miss france parce que je suis très
fier d'être miss france alors je sais
qu'il ya on parle beaucoup de
l'exhibitionnisme du fait d'être en
maillot de bain mais pourront que jeune
femme
cela nécessite beaucoup de courage et
beaucoup d'efforts sur soi pour arriver
devant lui millions de téléspectateurs
et assumer son corps mais je trouve que
on peut être à la fois féministe on peut
aimer les maillots de bercy lewin
absolument de combat qui n'ont qui n'ont
rien à voir dans ce qu'on fait un jeu
très très dangereux aujourd'hui c'est
que sous couvert de respecter le corps
de la femme sous couvert de progressisme
en fait on fait le jeu des plus des
radicalismes en fait les pieds en fait
des pressions extrêmes à tout à fait
d'accord que là vous allez un petit peu
loin mais je vais là où j'ai envie
d'aller
tu vas aller chez toi les doigts si vous
n'avez je vais chez moi mais c'est très
dangereux
non mais alors je m en magie le tuer le
sol d'accord avec moi oui il faut
arrêter et j'ai changé parce que
l'époque a changé
la société évolue et aujourd'hui pour
l'image de la femme que qu'on chérit
tous ici on ne peut plus défiler en
maillot de bain voilà c'est rétrograde
le sait mais oui tu viens d'aller leur
mère
vous allez me calmer on me demande mon
avis le dos vous donnerai le vôtre après
si on vous donne la parole ce qui n'est
pas sûr qu'ils font so lu ment changé et
il en va de la sauvegarde de miss france
qui ne comportent que j'aime
arrêtons avec ces maillots de jean-louis
je cherchais ce qu'on veut connaître le
sens du vent on écoute on écoute gît là
on est sûr de pas se tromper en tout cas
tu est sur d'avoir au cul dans aucun
emmerdes est ce que tu dis toujours dans
le sens de la bienséance on va bien mais
c'est bien pensante excuse moi c'est un
concours de collectionneurs tu veux les
faire défiler si vous voulez faire
défiler en doudoune et en bonne et la
joie pascale chaud quand tu n'es pas
bien sur la plage ça je l ai vu qu est
ce qu elle vaut également pour le corps
de la femme répond pas vous aimez ça
mais j'y jouerai eric de l'aude il
confond la pudeur et la pie xii je sais
et surtout en france elles sont jugés en
partie sur des critères physiques
écouter les preuves de maillots de bain
ça me semble pas complètement déplacé
dans ce cas là voilà alors je sais pas
dans quel monde doit vivre gilles mais
ces deux mois alors là on va pouvoir tue
on va revoir ce défilé en maillot de
bain que valérie bénaïm qualifie demande
de tartuffe marché regard des gens
calmes et arte les truffes le regarder
je ne suis pas d'accord regarde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est magique
j'attends l'avis du public pour la
stocker les vélos alors pardonnez moi
mais l'ajustement en plus on dirait des
robes je trouve que c'est quand même des
maillots de bain assez couvert pour le
mou si j'aurai tout une voix la plage
comme ça franchement faire des choses
dans la piscine la tombe du coup depuis
des années elle défile un maillot de
bain si les filles ne veulent pas
défilent en maillot de bain elles se
présentent pas ou gomis faire donc c'est
leur liberté pure et simple de la
liberté c'est à veulent se montrer en
maillot de bain à la télé pendant un
concours miss france elle se présente
sinon elle se présente pas de l'ormeau
c'est un concours j'ai besoin d'écrire
mode de l'ordre au cours de beauté un
concours de beauté on n'est pas jugé sur
la nudité sur la beauté c'est un
concours d'élégance et parce qu'on est
en train de lire ses mails satin qu'on
n'aurait pas élu pardon quand vous avez
une jolie fille dans votre chambre à
coucher ou un très bel vous la trouvez
belle nu vous le voulez demander de
mettre à un manteau de fourrure nom
passe passe à vincent perriot la mienne
et il faudrait des espaces pas ça dans
ma chambre
là il faut être extrêmement logique soit
c'est un concours de beauté et on les
voit défiler en mba soit c'est plus un
concours de beauté et on supprime cette
émission qui pour moi est vraiment la
pire et mais sur un monde le pire angle
pas le pire de ce que permettra de la
ram
ils sont encore là évidemment tout
paddock de gilles qui dit fois un
télémètre bas mais à côté de ça qui est
ça très très bon que chacun mais on est
la pouliche de l'année qui les vêtements
c'est donc pour représenter où placer
les gueux la vraie excusez moi y'a
quelqu'un vous n'êtes pas qu'on a
quelqu'un qui est mal
kaka était encore en larmes à fra bat
bien oui alors cyril rool non je vois
pas pourquoi vous voulez pas que les
faits vous de mettre en maillot de bain
j'aime autant vous que j'y monsieur la
visite il met mais toi aussi tu veux pas
dont vous mêlant des prénoms je ne vois
pas pourquoi voulait pas que les fans ce
matin mais demain à la piscine elle
sommet de bain à la plage et de son
médecin si les gens sont choqués de les
voir en maillot de bain une télécommande
je me baigne en pantalon violet
commandes on change de chaîne si ça vous
dérange 1 messieurs dames qui sont
dérangés vous changez de chaîne
la découverte est un petit truc qui me
fait rire c'est que là on s'offusque pas
de maillot de bain pas de manette bat
là-bas
hier il ya des filles qui sont venus là
oui le public mais c'est pas vous
envoyer les ai pas vus jouer groupé
savoir ça n'a rien à voir
l année des burgers
la hausse est bien esseulé vous le 6 de
dépasser d'hamburger à bien aller
essayer dans les mois à venir une
nouvelle attaque le style est là qu il
me semble qu a les bras
vernet-les-bains j'ai pas vu que j'étais
devant et derrière deux pas du tout que
j'étais devant la problème du corps de
la famille voir sa maîtresse ont
déchanté de la moi je vois je vois
souvent l'avis du public
je vois la vie du bowling center faut
que ça fait du baby ski open to fait 26
noms seront supprimés cg des producteurs
de l'émission aujourd'hui voilà c'est
que ces latitudes jamais remettre un
dessin tout pas même pas du tout le fait
de porter un maillot l attitude quand
elles marchent sans même plutôt elle a
diminué quand elle salue encore bien
marché qui a le colonel diry l'offre qui
vous attend pour l'opération camoufle
merci